Louisville Kentucky City Council now
plans to investigate how the mayor
responded to the deadly police shooting
of Brianna Taylor Taylor was killed back
in March and what her family calls a
botched police raid it added fuel to the
worldwide protests against police
brutality in this country and one of the
three officers involved has since been
fired but no criminal charges have been
filed against him that Officer is
appealing his firing saying it was
unjustified last week we spoke with
Brianna Taylor's mother Tameka Palmer
who has now filed a wrongful death
lawsuit she was in tears talking about
the support that she's received what
would be most helpful to you at this
time to continue to say her name - like
I said we're still just in the beginning
it's still so much work to be done so
just please continue to say her name
please continue to March in demand
justice Louisville Mayor Greg Fischer
joins us now to discuss her biana Taylor
case he says that he will work to
implement police reform in his new role
as president of the US Conference of
Mayors this is an interview that you'll
see only on CBS this morning and mayor
Fischer we thank you for joining us
today you've got a lot going on a lot to
discuss let's start with the Brianna
Taylor case so one officer has been
fired two others have not been fired you
satisfied where things stand in that
case right now
well good morning Gail thanks for having
me the guiding principle throughout
Brianna Taylor's tragedy has been get to
the truth get to the truth I've asked
the Attorney General the FBI the US
Attorney to be involved to make sure
that no matter what the outcome the
truth comes out so where the case is
right now is with the Attorney General
Daniel Cameron that he will be deciding
if any criminal charges will be filed on
this case in the meantime we're not
waiting for improvements
I signed Brianna's law into law a couple
weeks ago that bans the use of no-knock
warrants here in Louisville also
requires body cameras be used on all
search warrants so we're not waiting any
time we have an improvement opportunity
we swing into that that's what the US
Conference of Mayors will be doing also
as we look at broader police reform
around the country mm-hmm you're right
we all want the truth your apps
right about that and one officer has
been fired and I think Brianna Taylor's
mother and people who are very upset
about her death want the other two
officers to be fired
what do you think I know we're all
looking into the thing but you are the
mayor of the city your opinion matters
well the what's important is the truth
and that's why all these different
agencies are looking at this I'm
actually precluded by state law Believe
It or Not which I would really like to
see changed kr s 67 C from commenting
further on this case while its
investigation but that's why you want
the FBI and you want the Attorney
General and you want the US Attorney and
now it's with the Attorney General here
in the state of Kentucky to determine
what the next steps are going to be what
was your personal reaction when you
first heard about the circumstances of
Brianna Taylor's death what did you
think about the actions of your Police
Department well you're distraught I mean
I have kids that are about the ages and
not kids but young adults about the same
age as Brianna Taylor and and you put
yourself in the position Brianna's mom
and just say how would you react to
something like that and it's just a pit
in your stomach and they say how do you
move through these tragedies then as a
city to improve try to make sure
something like this never happens again
it's the nature of a mayor's job that
you occasionally have tragedy and then
you have to move forward and try to
bring your community with you at the
same time so it's certainly something
that we're extraordinarily sorry about
yeah a lot of people feel that way mr.
mayor yeah a lot of people also wonder
why it took 110 days for the city to
take any action and it was only after
there were national protests following
the death of George Floyd can you talk
about why it was so long before there
was any action in the case absolutely I
mean who has been a leader and the
release of body camera evidence after
when there's an officer-involved
shooting and that's one of the real
problems or challenges with this case is
there is no body camera footage these
were undercover narcotics officers
executing a search warrant
since then I've changed that policy so
unlike some of the other cases that we
see around the country
there's no direct evidence of what's
happened so that's when a Public
Integrity Unit investigation takes place
those typically last two to six months
probably about what 6070 days into this
case is when actions started being
taking in terms of what the facts were
that and we knew that we're coming out
in terms of improvement in the community
but the fundamental lack of body cameras
has been the big stumbling block in this
case yeah you know we mentioned
congratulations on your new position
because you're now head of the US
Conference of Mayors what do you all
think is the number one thing that can
be done to reduce these deadly
encounters with the police department
especially as it pertains to the black
community yeah I mean this is a time of
real potential transformation for our
country I hope when you've got a
pandemic we've got an economic recession
that we've got marches for racial
justice taking place there is no
question that the climate is right for a
serious change in all types of societal
issues and police reform is absolutely
one of those the police have got to
decide to be part of that I know good
cops definitely want to as well sanctity
of life has always got to be the number
one issue de-escalation has got to be a
guiding principle for all of these as
well and then the community has to see
itself as part of cooperating to build
safety in a community with trust in the
police department so there's no question
that there's a lot of challenges that
need to there need to be addressed
mayors are uniquely situated in the in
the country to be able to take a lot of
these issues on and I can tell you
mayors are leaning into that right now
police reform and racial justice is one
of our top priorities as we head into
this new year
well mayor it seems like a tough time
for you I'm thinking if you're if you
feel like you're wearing gasoline
underpants because you've got the police
department on one hand demanding your
resignation they say they feel
underappreciated unsupported then you
have the police reform protesters who
are saying you're not doing enough both
sides are calling for your resignation
how are you navigating this process for
yourself standing in the upright
position well that's kind of the nature
of being a mayor in America today and
then
all over America right now that's that's
why the conditions are ripe for
transformation so we have not been in a
place like this in America now for about
50 years or so so the question is will
we get it right this time I think the
conditions are right and I'm hopeful
that it will when you look at addressing
some of the underlying challenges that
America has right now in terms of the
wealth and income gap that we have now
is the time where we need to change the
minimum wage to a living wage now is the
time when we need to develop and prepare
reparations proposals for African
Americans to address this wealth gap in
our country so now is the time to to
recover from the Cova tax so we get
direct federal funding so city budgets
can stay healthy to provide basic
services so the nature of a mayor's job
is handling difficulty turning that into
Hope in action so your citizens can be
in a better place and that's what the
mayors of America are going to do well
mayor Fischer you got a lot to do and as
you said everybody wants to get it right
but also people believe now is the time
for change thank you sir for your time
this one